Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
manscape luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Música]
el 3 de noviembre de este año 2022 in
rancan el ex Primer Ministro de Pakistán
sufrió un intento de asesinato meses
antes en abril de este mismo año este
hombre había dimitido tras una moción de
confianza en el parlamento veréis si
habláramos de cualquier otro país
diríamos que están en una crisis
política realmente preocupante sin
embargo esto es Pakistán y aquí las
crisis políticas salvajes lo llaman
jueves por la tarde llevan sumidos en el
caos político y económico desde su
independencia y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos Y a mí qué más me da lo
que ocurra en en Pakistán en Pakistán
Pues mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik Pakistán nos debería
importar Y mucho por tres simples
razones la primera es que es el quinto
país con más población del mundo más de
220 millones de habitantes Pero además
es uno de los pocos países con armas
nucleares y su doctrinas nuclear
podríamos definirla como de gatillo
fácil en teoría basta con que alguien
invada su territorio para que puedan
lanzar una bomba nuclear Pero esperad
porque todavía hay una tercera razón
terrorismo Pakistán tiene toda clase de
grupos terroristas y en muchos casos por
el propio estado de hecho sabéis dónde
mataron a Osama Bin Laden efectivamente
en Pakistán y no creéis que era en
unzulo cualquiera perdido por las
montañas sino la ciudad de abotavazquez
para que os hagáis una idea es como el
Beverly Hills Cómo podría alguien
ignorar a un país como Pakistán que
parece que la mínima va a estallar
literalmente la verdad que entran
escalofríos solo de pensar en que el
quinto país más poblado del mundo que
además tiene armas nucleares y que está
plagado de terrorismo acabe cayéndose en
pedazos por la economía y es que la
situación en Pakistán es crítica tras
décadas de inestabilidad ahora mismo
están al borde del colapso y diréis Pero
cómo han llegado a este punto en
Pakistán porque está tan sumamente mal
que es lo que les está lastrando tanto
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes este año la Navidad se ha
adelantado en visualpolitik nos acaban
de regalar el performa empaques 4.0 de
manscape vamos a echarle un vistazo este
kit de higiene y afeitado de manscape
cubre todas tus necesidades desde la
cabeza hasta los pies literalmente para
empezar incluye la Joya de la corona la
recortadora inalámbrica launmower 4.0
con su tecnología avanzada skin save que
nos ayuda a evitar Cortes y enganchones
en las zonas más sensibles del cuerpo
viene con una luz led muy práctica a la
hora de afeitarse en esas noches oscuras
y frías de invierno este kit también nos
incluye el withwaker la recortadora para
el vello de la nariz y las orejas con
cuchillas giratorias de 360 grados en el
momento en el que empieces a usarla te
darás cuenta de que no sabrás vivir sin
ella pero esto no es todo porque Además
este paquete incluye el desodorante
íntimo propio server y el spray tónico
íntimo crop reviver y además por si todo
esto era poco también recibiréis dos
regalos esta bolsa de aseo y un boxer
manscape anti rozaduras que podéis ver
por aquí Y como siempre tenemos un
descuento muy especial para todos
vosotros que seguís visualpolitik
básicamente si utilizáis el código vpes
conseguireis un 25% de descuento más el
envío internacional gratuito y los dos
Regalos y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
la caja de Pandora pakistaní
sabíais que en Pakistán nunca ningún
Primer Ministro que haya ganado unas
elecciones ha acabado su mandato habéis
oído bien Pakistán lleva sumido en las
tinieblas de la inestabilidad política
desde su creación de hecho el intento de
asesinato me arrancan no es más que uno
más de una larga lista en la caótica
historia de Pakistán Y la verdad viendo
cómo han acabado otros en su mismo cargo
podemos decir que este hombre ha tenido
bastante suerte porque sabéis cómo
acabaron el resto pues o bien acusados
de corrupción y en la cárcel o bien
exiliados o incluso asesinados Como por
ejemplo el caso de la única primera
ministra mujer que ha tenido este país
Ven a decir but a la que asesinaron
cuando estaba presentándose para un
tercer mandato así que bueno creo que ya
vais cogiendo la idea pero vamos a
frenar un poco para entender Por qué
Pakistán está como está veréis Pakistán
se independizó en el año 1947 del
imperio británico como ocurrió con la
India pero esperad un momento porque la
Pakistán que conocemos hoy en día no es
la que se independizó
cuando Pakistán se liberó de las cadenas
británicas estaba dividido en dos
territorios el Pakistán del este y el
del Oeste es decir lo que ahora es el
Pakistán que conocemos y bangladesh
pronto surgieron tensiones étnicas que
llevaron a una guerra civil que terminó
por separar ambos territorios y en 1973
casi dos años después del fin de la
guerra Pakistán aprobó una nueva
constitución esta Constitución reconoce
el islam como religión oficial aunque
también acepta algunos elementos de
secularismo
por supuesto Pakistán no es ni mucho
menos una democracia perfecta y de hecho
tiene dos grandes problemas su seguridad
y sus instituciones políticas veréis en
Pakistán el ejército domina todo el
funcionamiento de la sociedad y no se le
escapa ni una lógicamente entre sus
cometidos está la seguridad del país
pero su estrategia contra la eterna
enemiga India es bastante drástica de
hecho el propio ejército bautizó esta
estrategia con el nombre tan poético de
desangrar a la India con mil cortes
habéis oído bien este nombre existe y es
oficial y diréis en qué consiste pues
muy simple en entrenar a grupos
Insurgentes para desestabilizar a la
India y por eso no extraña que nos
encontremos con noticias como esta
Pakistán entrenó a grupos clandestinos
de militares para luchar contra Indian
cachemira el expresidente Pakistán en
una entrevista con espiguel pero no
creáis que solo han financiado estos
grupos para desestabilizar a la India
fijaos en lo que dijo el propio ex
Primer Ministro in rancan atentos el
ejército Pakistán y entreno al caída y
estos grupos para luchar en Afganistán
vamos que ni siquiera los propios
dirigentes de Pakistán niegan que hayan
financiado grupos terroristas Y diréis a
quién creéis que le está afectando esto
Ahora pues exactamente a Pakistán
cría cuervos y te sacarán los ojos como
podéis ver Pakistán está repleto de
grupos terroristas activos que atacan
continuamente ciudades y pueblos del
país no se salvan y la propia capital
islamabad y por si todo esto fuera poco
los pobres ciudadanos del país han
tenido que tragar con gobiernos
tremendamente inestables hasta el día de
hoy hablamos de golpes de estado como el
de 1977 o el de 1999 corrupción sin
freno asesinatos de políticos vamos un
sindios y adivináis por cortesía de
quién Exacto lo habéis adivinado el
ejército otra vez el ejército se ha
dedicado a quitar y poner a primeros
ministros a diestro y siniestro y muchas
veces con la ayuda de los jueces y os
preguntaréis Pero por qué está el
ejército tan interesado en manejar la
política Pues por una sencilla razón
para proteger sus intereses económicos
veréis el ejército es dueño directo de
más de 50 empresas Y se cree que a
través de tiene miles de empresas más
bajos de control en total el ejército
pakistaní estaría involucrado en
negocios valorados en más de 20.000
millones de dólares y no son empresas
cualquiera sino empresas que copan casi
todos los mercados nacionales en los que
están por ejemplo el del cereal los
fertilizantes o la distribución de gas y
como os podéis imaginar en el momento en
el que el ejército ve sus intereses en
peligro no duda en acusar al Primer
Ministro de turno de corrupción
[Música]
y como os podéis imaginar en un país con
tanta inestabilidad política un ejército
que controla buena parte de la economía
del país y un montón de inseguridad
debido al terrorismo que ha generado en
muchos casos el propio estado la
decadencia económica del país está
asegurada Y si a todo esto lo unimos que
Pakistán apenas produce gran cosa a
excepción de unos cuantos mangos aceites
vegetales y camiones pues ya tenemos el
póker de ases de hecho la balanza
comercial Es realmente pésima fijaos de
entre los tres grandes países del
subcontinente Indio Pakistán es el que
tienen los peores datos en lo que supone
a las exportaciones en relación con el
pib es un indicador de su pobre apertura
al exterior y la pobre competitividad de
sus empresas pero claro si todos los
problemas de Pakistán fueran estos Pues
tampoco estaríamos haciendo este vídeo
atentos porque todo esto no ha hecho más
que empezar
el mejor amigo de Pakistán
[Música]
si quisierais poner unos paneles solares
en vuestra casa y no tuvierais dinero
que haríais obviamente pediréis un
préstamo verdad pues en cierta forma
para que están hecho lo mismo aunque
cambiando inversión por gasto corriente
como ha querido ofrecer servicios
públicos pero no tenía dinero porque su
economía no da para más sea endeudado el
país tiene ahora mismo una deuda tan
grande como el 70% de su pib y ya sé lo
que me vais a decir a ver un 70% no
parece tan alto si lo comparamos con
otros países como España Por ejemplo que
está en el 120%, Y sí tenéis razón pero
la diferencia es que Pakistán no tiene
una economía tan desarrollada como para
soportar semejante nivel de
endeudamiento el riesgo político la
falta de ingresos públicos y todos los
problemas que os hemos descrito hacen
que uno la demanda por deuda pakistaní
sea muy baja y dos que los tipos en los
que se financian sean muchísimo más
altos y si tenemos en cuenta Estos
factores menos dinero disponible e
intereses más altos entonces este 70% de
deudas sí que se convierte en un
problema de hecho sus bonos de deuda
están calificados bonos basura porque
claro La pregunta es quién en su sano
juicio les prestaría dinero pues voy a
decir quién aparte del fmi o del Banco
Mundial su mejor amigo china Exacto el
gigante asiático es el principal
acreedor de Pakistán
Pakistán fue uno de los primeros países
en reconocer a China en 1951 ambos
Tenían un adversario común la India de
hecho con el estallido de la guerra
entre la India y China en 1962 ambos
países empezaron a cooperar militarmente
en los últimos años casi un 40% de las
exportaciones de armas de China van a
Pakistán en los años 90 esta cooperación
se extendió el terreno económico y desde
2015 acordaron crear un corredor
económico
y ya sé lo que me vais a preguntar pero
de verdad le interesa tanto a China
comercial con un país que apenas se
sostiene pues lo cierto es que sí
atentos a este mapa lo que veis aquí es
el puerto de guardar construido por
China y atentos porque este Puerto es
muy importante podría llegado el caso
ser el salvavidas de China y diréis Pero
por qué pues seguir mirando el mapa
china compra petróleo a los Países
Árabes y ese petróleo viaja por barco y
pasa por las costas de la India en
cualquier momento la India Estados
Unidos o alguno de sus aliados podría
cortar el tránsito bastaría con cerrar
estos tres estrechos que veis en
pantalla para bloquear Prácticamente
todo el tránsito de petróleo hacia china
sin embargo si estos barcos atracan en
Pakistán podrían enviar el petróleo por
tierra es decir que la India o Estados
Unidos no tendrían Tan sencillo eso de
cortar el tránsito y a ver esta le va a
venir muy bien a China pero que saca de
esto Pakistán pues unos 62.000 millones
de dólares en proyectos de construcción
de infraestructuras si Pakistán quiere
tener una economía productiva necesita
puertos ferrocarriles y carreteras y
como ya hemos visto muy se atreverían a
poner el dinero en la mesa para
construirlos Por qué pues aparte de
todas las razones que ya hemos dado hay
una gran razón el terrorismo
como ya hemos dicho Pakistán está
plagado de grupos terroristas
de todos los colores grupos
independentistas vamos la lista es
interminable y todo esto hace que
incluso china tenga problemas cuando
quiera construir un puerto atentos 26 de
abril de 2022 Pakistán ciudadano chinos
asesinados en un atentado en karachi
para que os hagáis una idea china han
llegado a proponer que amuray en todo el
puerto del guardar para protegerlo de
grupos terroristas y todo esto explica
que estos préstamos de China vengan con
unos intereses mucho más altos que los
del fmi para que os hagáis una idea
donde el fmi cobra un interés del 3%
china cobra un interés del 6,5%. En
otras palabras Pakistán es muy poco
productivo tiene mucho riesgo y a la vez
mantiene una duda salvaje con el fmi y
con China y os preguntaréis Y qué tal se
llevan con los Estados Unidos pues como
os podéis imaginar las relaciones están
en es complicado por un lado Estados
Unidos es el principal mercado de
productos pakistaníes de lo poco que
exporta pakistaní que es bastante poco
El Tío Sam es su comprador más
importante ahora bien en el terreno
político instalaciones Pues no son tan
buenas
[Música]
durante la Guerra Fría Pakistán fue un
Aliado contra la unión soviética En
aquellos años Washington llegó a
entrenar a grupos Insurgentes para que
lucharan contra los soviéticos sin
embargo Todo cambió cuando Pakistán
inició su programa nuclear de un día
para otro la Casa Blanca cortó todo el
suministro de armas hacia este país pero
sin duda alguna la manzana de la
discordia es el terrorismo Pakistán es
un lugar refugio para un montón de
grupos terroristas pensadlo bien Osama
Bin Laden estaba escondido en uno de los
mejores barrios a las afueras de
abotabad su casa además estaba a poco
más de un kilómetro de la academia
militar de Pakistán Vamos Que
prácticamente eran vecinos Pero por
supuesto nadie sabía nada Es más cuando
los Navy seals entraron en la casa donde
estaba Bin Laden tuvieron que invadir el
espacio aéreo de Pakistán Y esto no le
hizo la más mínima gracia al gobierno
pakistaní pero todo esto es tema para
otro vídeo hoy vamos a centrarnos en la
economía de este país porque como
decíamos Pakistán está endeudado hasta
las cejas es más quieren pagar la deuda
que ya tienen con más deuda y como os
podéis imaginar Esta es la receta
perfecta para terminar en un colapso de
proporciones Nacho vidalianas solo hacía
falta un evento sorpresa para terminar
dando el traste con todo el país y qué
os voy a decir los últimos años han
estado llenos de eventos sorpresa ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
con la gran decepción
habéis visto los vídeos que hemos
dedicado a la crisis energética en
Europa si recordáis en estos últimos
meses la Consigna en Europa ha sido
pagaremos lo que haga falta con tal de
llenar nuestros depósitos de gas natural
eso implica que muchos barcos de gas
natural licuado que iban con destino
Asia y eran La media vuelta a pocas
millas del puerto y se fueran a Europa
donde pagaban muchísimo más todo esto
son relativamente buenas noticias para
Europa Pero hay un claro perdedor los
países asiáticos que se quedan sin gas y
diréis Quién ha sido uno de los grandes
afectados por esta crisis Exacto
Pakistán veréis en estos últimos cuatro
años Pakistán ha sufrido varios cambios
políticos y económicos los grandes
partidos políticos a saber el partido
del pueblo y la liga musulmana de
Pakistán de nahuatl han visto su dominio
en peligro
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea el partido
del pueblo es el partido que más veces
ha gobernado en Pakistán por hacer un
resumen rápido podríamos decir que son
lo más parecido a un partido
socialdemócrata occidental la liga
musulmana sin embargo sería el
equivalente a un partido conservador
sin embargo en el año 2018 apareció el
clásico outside de la política llamado a
romper con el bipartidismo el típico
líder carismático que promete Maravillas
en campaña electoral en este caso además
se trataba de toda una estrella del
cricket que como sabéis es el deporte
nacional en Pakistán de quién estamos
hablando exacto de inram el partido
político de ingram se presentó a las
elecciones de 2018 prometiendo mejorar
la economía y construir un estado de
bienestar bajo un socialismo islámico
además como los dos grandes partidos del
país estaban podridos de corrupción
aprovechó para presentarse también con
un mensaje anticorrupción y qué creéis
que ocurrió pues evidentemente acabó
ganando Pero por desgracia la suerte no
le acompañó después de las elecciones
Poco después de ganar tuvo que
enfrentarse a su primera crisis la
crisis del cómic ya sabéis que la crisis
de la pandemia frenó toda la economía
mundial en seco y Pakistán no iba a ser
la excepción y si su economía ya estaba
estancada de por sí el coronavirus no lo
puso mucho mejor pero espero de momento
porque esto es solo el principio A ver
cuál diríais que es la principal fuente
energía en el mix de Pakistán Exacto el
gas natural
[Música]
sin embargo este país no tiene ninguna
conexión internacional a través de
gasoductos han intentado construir uno
con Rusia y otro con Irán pero por el
momento ninguno de estos proyectos se ha
materializado Pues bien Pakistán produce
algo más de la mitad del gas que consume
pero el resto lo tiene que importar Y
diréis cómo llega el gasa Pakistán
Exacto por barcos de gas natural licuado
y si sois veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik ya sabéis que el gas
natural licuado es mucho más caro que el
que llega Por gasoducto y en Pakistán el
dinero no sabrá precisamente conclusión
Pues atentos un apagón eléctrico en todo
el país pone a Pakistán en la oscuridad
y esperad un momento porque esta noticia
es de antes de la Guerra de Ucrania es
decir antes de que todos esos barcos
metaneros dieran la vuelta antes de
llegar los puertos de Pakistán y se
marchar en Europa así que ya os podéis
imaginar lo que está ocurriendo ahora en
pleno 2022 con la crisis energética
apagones masivos precios altísimos por
la energía y fábricas paradas conclusión
pues que todo ese estado del bienestar y
esa economía próspera Que tanto prometí
en rancan en campaña electoral Ahora
parece una broma de mal gusto Mientras
tanto acreedores quieren recuperar sus
deudas y Pakistán ha terminado de
evaluando su propia divisa
[Música]
como podéis ver en esta gráfica un dólar
estadounidense ha pasado de costar 100
rupias en 2017 a costar más del doble en
2022 el resultado aún más inflación para
los ya sufridos ciudadanos pakistaníes
si os fijáis bien acán se le estaban
acumulando los mismos síntomas que
presentaba si ranca antes de colapsar y
de los que por cierto ya hemos hablado
en este canal deuda elevada inflación
Nacho vidaliana moneda de valuada y
escasez y por eso como parecía aquí en
rancan era incapaz de solucionar todos
estos problemas que se le estaban
acumulando el 10 de Abril de 2022 le
echaron pero a diferencia del resto de
primeros ministros que le antecedieron
al menos a este no le han acusado de
corrupción sino que fue el propio
parlamento el que le echó a través de
una moción de censura Es la primera vez
que en Pakistán echan de esta manera un
Primer Ministro y desde entonces
Pakistán tiene un gobierno provisional
en este caso la liga musulmana que es de
Centro derecha ha vuelto al poder y ya
han dicho que no convocarán nuevas
elecciones hasta haber hecho algunas
reformas para estabilizar el país el
nuevo presidente es Bass sharif tiene
una tarea colosal por delante pero ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros Cómo creéis
que el nuevo gobierno solucionará todos
estos problemas si es que es posible
solucionarlos qué creéis que debe ser su
prioridad acabará pa que están como sri
lanka Y si fuera así Qué implicaciones
creéis que tendría para la seguridad
internacional podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]